[Música]
escala en París Ahí va para la
u Bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio Francia internacional y de France
24 desde hace 60 años Cuba manda
abrigadas de médicos a países que los
necesitan ya sea por catástrofes
naturales epidemias como el ébola
guerras o por sistemas de salud
precarios o por acuerdos de cooperación
con países amigos con la crisis del
covid Vimos aterrizar a médicos cubanos
en países mucho más ricos como Italia
donde el personal sanitario no daba
abasto y a día de hoy aún siguen yendo
Hoy hace escala en París la periodista
mileys equidad que ha publicado una
investigación sobre este tema Muchísimas
gracias mileys por estar con nosotros
muchas gracias a ustedes por la
invitación mileys que es periodista
independiente integrante del colectivo
extramuros press y que es autora de este
libro médicos cubanos los ejércitos de
la publicado en francés cuéntenos Cuál
es la Génesis de este libro
empecé a escribir este libro en 2020
durante el primer confinamiento Porque
leí un artículo simplemente sobre
médicos cubanos que fueron enviados a
Italia para ayudar los médicos italianos
a enfrentar esta pandemia de covid
empecé a documentar esa Avenida empecé a
interesarme a la historia de esas
brigadas cubanas de médicos y tenía
tantas informaciones que decidí ir a
Cuba a hacer investigación sobre el tema
y escribir un libro la OMS
reconoce la labor de de estos médicos
cubanos hay casi 100.000 médicos en una
isla con 11 millones de militantes
explíquenos Qué son exactamente estas
misiones de médicos cubanos las misiones
de médicos cubanos empezaron en el
1963 en Argelia cuando el país o su
independencia y
se encontraron con pocos médicos Porque
casi todos fueron franceses que
regresaron a Francia y Guerra y la
descolonización exacto y Argelia y llamó
a Cuba que fue un país amigo del frente
de liberación nacional para enviar a
médicos llegaron a Argelia curaron a
mucha gente y así empezaron esas
misiones
internacionalistas de ayuda
con la con la salud
después Cuba empezó a enviar médicos y
militares en países donde habían
movimientos de independencia como Angola
verdad como Angola coma Congo y otros
con el tiempo pararon las misiones
militares pero siguieron las misiones
medicales Cuba siempre se ha vendido
como una potencia médica efectivamente
con un sistema de salud para todos eso
se refleja en el libro sin embargo y
usted también lo relata en esta
investigación y lo vivió en primera
persona hubo unas manifestaciones el 11
de julio de 2021 usted estaba ahí y los
cubanos manifestaban por primera vez
Desde hacía muchísimo tiempo 27 años y
entre lo que denunciaban también estaba
la escasez de alimentos es un poco
contradictorio Cómo se explica
si la situación social y económica de
Cuba es muy mala los cubanos sufren
mucho afecta el sistema sanitario afecta
al sistema sanitario Cuba tiene muy buen
médico muy bien formados tienen muchos
médicos con técnicas y métodos clínicos
que que han hecho pruebas y pero Cuba
tiene un embargo y vive con un bloqueo
desde 60 años que imponen los Estados
Unidos y que no permiten importar
materias primas para producir
medicamentos
que nos permite importar medicamentos
alimentos
básicamente nada Y entonces ese sistema
de salud no permite a los médicos de
trabajar como podrían trabajar porque no
tienen recursos material no pueden
importar jeringuillas mascarillas
respiradores tecnologías para máquinas
medicales Y entonces la situación se
pone bastante difícil porque problemas
de salud Aparecen por esa falta de
recursos eso sería una de las causas el
embargo también se critica mucho la
gestión del gobierno del gobierno cubano
ha entrevistado a varios médicos en la
isla y quería preguntarle cuál es el
perfil Cómo viven Cuánto cobran porque
se ha criticado También muchas de estas
muchas de estas brigadas luego lo
veremos Cuál es el perfil Cómo viven
hay muchos perfiles ahí jóvenes
hay médicos más viejos hay médicos
especialistas hay médicos generales hay
básicamente de todo hay médicos que se
van por la aventura cuando se más
jóvenes y que quieren viajar y hay
médicos que se van de Misión para ganar
más dinero porque se gana mucho más
dinero cuando se va de Misión que cuando
se ejerce en Cuba exacto y muchos
médicos Perdón se van en varias misiones
en sus vidas una dos pueden ser cuatro o
cinco o seis misiones
Cómo explica que hayan tenido que ir a
países
como Italia o Francia la Guyana Francesa
países ricos durante el covid por
ejemplo
eso se explica por el hecho que países
en Europa tienen
tienen decisiones políticas que
que no permiten a los sistemas de salud
pública de desarrollarse por ejemplo en
Francia se quitan muchas camas en
hospitales hay recortes no la
financiación de la sanidad en Europa Sí
sí claro y hay muchos desiertos
medicales faltan muchísimos médicos en
Francia en zonas Rurales en zonas pobres
pero también a Italia España en
muchísimos países y entonces
los
gobiernos y aman a Cuba para ayudarles
porque a veces es
el único recurso que tienen y ha sido el
caso de Italia que es donde nace no esa
idea de esa investigación el papel de
estos médicos ha sido muy importante
en situaciones muy tensas como la que se
vivió con la epidemia de ébola en África
hasta Estados Unidos no que bueno sin
embargo a Cuba reconoció esa labor de
esos médicos estaban preparados usted
Habla con el médico Juan Jesús alemán
que estuvo creo que en Liberia estaban
preparados para para eso porque fue una
crisis bastante fuerte no en muchos
países
a ver técnicamente fueron preparados
porque en la Habana antes de irse a
Liberia fueron formados a demiología
a la situación del país luego llegar
Exacto tenían teoría pero cuando
llegaron me dijo Juan Jesús alemán que
nadie estaba preparado por eso porque
llegaron en un desastre donde la la
ébola Así es 100% muertos
donde los médicos se fueron por miedo de
quedarse y de contagiarse contagiarse Y
entonces llegaron
y han tenido que poner
a tiendas de emergencia para trabajar en
condiciones muy difíciles porque estaban
casi solos con los pacientes
y fue mucho miedo
fueron seis meses terribles para ellos
pero cuando se fueron habían resultados
lo comentábamos antes no solo se dicen
bondades de estas brigadas
la ONU y human rightwoods habla de este
sistema de médicos como esclavitud
moderna con normas draconianas de
conducta que violan numerosos derechos
básicos de los médicos esto lo dice
human right watch
incluso José Miguel Vivanco que fue el
director para las Américas de Human
rightwoods
hablan de que ni siquiera O sea dicta a
los médicos con quién vivir de quién se
pueden o no enamorar y hasta con quién
se les es permitido hablar ha habido
casos de desertores de médicos que
aprovechan esas misiones para desertar e
irse a otros países
desertores que han sido detenidos países
amigos de cuba porque desertaban usted
ha podido hablar de este tema con los
médicos ha podido hablar con desertores
[Música]
para mí la situación es mucho más
menos romántica menos romántica Exacto
son médicos que son pagados unos 100
euros en Cuba van de Misión son pagados
mil o más de 1000 euros dólares Claro
que hay gente que decide quedarse
y esos médicos se quedan porque
no quieren regresar a Cuba por las
condiciones de vida porque quieren
casarse en el lugar donde están porque
tienen hijos en el país donde están o
porque van a cobrar más y porque van a
cobrar más todo eso explica el hecho que
que que se pueden quedar
pero sí creo que que analizamos esa
situación de manera
muy romántica Y que cuando se habla con
ellos
son doctores que hablan de manera mucho
más simple de la situación sí decidí
quedarme mi novio vino a vivir conmigo
él quería viajar había una oportunidad
de trabajo donde donde vivimos y nos
reunimos aquí pero tienen dos críticas
principales el salario en demisión que
porque cobran una parte del salario Y al
Estado toma otra parte y Segundo si
deciden quedarse en el país donde fueron
de Misión no pueden regresar a Cuba para
ocho años Esas son las dos críticas
principales va a investigar un poquito
más ya nos queda muy muy poco tiempo
sobre este asunto si la semana próxima
voy a Italia y voy a encontrar los
médicos cubanos que están allá por una
misión de tres años o más bueno pues ya
a la vuelta de esa misión a ver si si
podemos hablar y nos cuenta más cosas
Muchísimas gracias mileys kedir por
haber estado con nosotros y mucho éxito
Con este libro sobre los médicos cubanos
Muchas gracias a todos ustedes también
por habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir por internet en rf y
mundo.com y en France 24.com Hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]